recall that according to President
Donald Trump Hillary Clinton could not
be trusted to handle sensitive secret
and classified information we've now
learned that random guests at Donald
Trump's Florida resort mar-a-lago knew
more about the plan to assassinate
Iranian leader Kasim soleimani then did
our own members of Congress according to
a new report Congress was not informed
of the administration's planned military
attack on sulemani our European allies
as I told you yesterday were not
informed per The Daily Beast during the
days leading up to the assassination of
soleimani Trump started to drop quote
hints to close associates and club goers
that something huge was coming and quote
specifically mentioned he'd been in
close contact with his top national
security and military advisers on gaming
out options for an aggressive action
that could quickly materialize Donald
Trump was reportedly walking around his
Club mar-a-lago in Florida saying he had
a big response planned to Iran that
people would be reading about it quote
very soon and meanwhile he was tweeting
about Iran having to pay a big price he
kept saying you'll see one of the
sources recalled describing a
conversation with Trump days before
Thursday's strike totally cool totally
legal a totally responsible thing for a
president to do random people at
mar-a-lago had more of a hint that
something was upcoming on Iran a bigger
hint than the gang of eight had in
Congress never mind the total lack of
congressional authorization that Trump
claimed presidents needed back when
Trump wasn't president and Barack Obama
was it is absolutely unconscionable that
the mar-a-lago thing has been allowed to
continue but why wouldn't it there have
been no consequences to anything that
Donald Trump does if you want access to
Trump you can get it by signing up for a
membership at mar-a-lago $200,000
initiation fee 14,000 dollars a year in
dues this is a direct funnel of money
from people to Trump's businesses for
access to the president of the United
States even to a front-row seat of Trump
miss handling sensitive national
security information but we don't have
to worry because his don't he's donating
his $400,000 salary so it's all fine
people whose names we don't even know
get to hear from Trump about sensitive
plans while my taxpayer dollars and your
taxpayer dollars are funneled into
Donald Trump's Club for security rooms
for Trump staffers rooms for Secret
Service golf cart rentals shrimp
cocktail for Donald Trump if I were a
foreign diplomat I would immediately
just sign up for a mar-a-lago membership
it's not an extravagance it's a
geopolitical investment at this point in
time why do you think the initiation fee
doubled at mar-a-lago from $100,000 to
$200,000 after Donald Trump was elected
president this is profiteering
but it's profiteering that puts national
security at risk and it's profiteering
on the basis of president of the of a
President of the United States
essentially selling access to himself at
his club it's happening blatantly is
happening boldly and there are actually
suggestions that the stock trades of
mar-a-lago members should be
investigated to look for patterns and
see if there's evidence of insider
trading on the basis of Donald Trump
saying things while roaming the halls is
this the type of winning we were told we
would get under President Donald Trump
this is a red alert Danger and after our
interview I am going to talk about we
increasingly need to be putting the
pressure on Republican elected officials
who are unwilling to deal with this
Trump is horrible the people around him
are horrible there's no question about
it
but we talk about oh we might need 65 or
70 million votes to remove this guy in
November of 2020 20 Republicans could do
it
14 cabinet members could do it and we'll
talk about that a little bit later in
the meantime make sure to vote in our
poll about what you think will happen in
Iran follow the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show and while
you're there follow me on instagram at
david pakman quick break and much more
coming up today